[Music]
this is the picture Madame Curie
I think definitely one of my heroes how
many are we okay start mark of course
I'm looking forward to discover dark
metal and hopefully make a change and
ultimately get was a prize for it and
the highest price that will be the noble
prize
the search for Dark Matter especially
now is definitely a race it has always
been a race and it's a very tough
competition
here at the Gran Sasso National
Laboratory which is the largest lab
worldwide for underground physics we
have created the most sensitive detector
for dark matter search this competition
is actually whew all the progress that
we have seen last ten years really but
you want to do it first which is what I
have been trying to do we know what kind
of signature we are looking for because
if that is the real particle which
explains the dark metal then these damn
particles must reach us even at these
grants also labs sometime
so we have this gran sasso mountains
above us to protect the sensitive
experiment from this radiation which
comes from the cosmos mostly sometimes
people wonder why we are taking longer
than we promised or that we wrote or
that they think and I think maybe they
don't realize how challenging the effort
is the Zenon people are really
professors here and there and each one
has postdocs young research graduate
students undergraduate there was no text
they're excited fuzzy monkey when you
want to do something good you have to
give up thank you very much okay Canada
[Music]
we messed up
yeah I was also the supporting actor
both literally and just really the Solis
thing to do every six years ago I think
I came to you thinking for a job and now
we know why she's not come on just that
the earthly and Apple stuff she she
pushed me to move to New York
[Music]
pushing the button so that scene is very
complicated for the unblinding that in
the conference room in my life Patrick
was the analysis coordinates as we look
at the data that we are taking from
other
you take the viewer each other keeping
this onions fully explained people you
know bring these nice shots of the of
the beach
this Sun like collecting a box of sand
over this specific idea and then we're
trying to literally just a few simple
accent but humans are they're very good
very good imaginations we're very good
at seeing things they're not there and
so the result without me to prove to
that so we lie to ourselves basically
everything the box is box we don't look
at it during this whole procedure of
collecting that they use our best sight
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
they casino to such a dock matter give
up detective quality not baby only with
a lot kilogram Xena inside I'd break
panties and know every night liking this
and what city is event you believe China
booked for dark matter and now we have
the best objector involved to town de
cuisine ax
you want because you know well that the
thing about working with the group at a
time only have about that's and had
people teach we're surrounded student
project and now we have more that market
when I want fifty people at seven
institutions
so you just needs one of the cooperating
institution and decision protect and
then we work the very last two years
Doosan they've got effect from a
detective need to be chapter to the US a
lot of students welcome to theta or can
see so many voters attention to this
table of up head over here but that this
is something that joint be on so this is
a Miss periodic table the elements now
there's 150 first year and all right
column easy element number 54 which is
Dina how to play a huge role in this and
this are my favorite
you talk a little bit about that you
know like I shouldn't ever microphone
yourself learn about this because they
wouldn't see nothin why do you care
about evenings like you want to read on
ahead is one the other kind of heavy and
it exists here at heart million that'll
make seven from here and get a museum
even when a Holocaust about communion
calls for time and a lot of professions
about the 1660 time for you
so the anomaly turns out we can't easily
cured by this economic to remove all
creative activities the impurity inside
to a very low level poverty dinner and
make a year without any fashion you want
material uses be that dollar to be
breaking that no traceability and
committing the darkness II so that see
no one
as well so we would have
[Music]
interesting summer student is regarding
technology to detect where events and
see actually that technology to for
following up on the nature of anything
so - enugu gamma-ray educated looking
going back to my footage all the
elements which may have different
activities in supernova moba with the
respective to be losing time detection
chamber so the purpose was not
documented
for rare plants or finding or anything
from supernova identified when the issue
and see people return it to the audience
for their questions and comments and
I'll turn those speeches I would like to
inspire you but what inspired you who
wants to make a movie about you know
that our result drove about scientist
how do you know it's like this
extroverted look if you're shooting
they're talking to you instead of drama
inductor what gave you the confidence
that this would make such a dramatic
dramatic personating as is my
understanding the necessary element
don't so one thing about filmmaking if
it isn't it license kind of a limited
license to pursue curiosity and tech but
film like making my friends of a midlife
crisis or something maybe like I left
the movie the first films I mean our
culture first one was about Burning Man
comes to Burning Man
but they cut learn they are the
documentary I realized to build was a
platform to suit a Python important that
I care about and science is something
that I always cared about and this sort
of grand human quest for truth and what
does it all mean
it's something that I cared about
ever since I was a little gay today but
sort of got lost and sort of the tax
base to pursue it and tell some of my
friends consulting that ugly said but I
I hate was the friend of mine basically
said look if you wanna make a film about
physics how I said I would look for the
greatest mysteries of today and they
would look for wearable potential
roll over if it goes one way it will
change everything available to change
everything but where's the threshold
finished paramedic that's an interesting
place to explore exciting stories of
physics that we chopped up a pass
through all the people who are on the
threshold saw these different amenities
I would go out to all these places like
this feature of the latest lab on a
little treatment that I wrote they said
I'm going to go to the underground labs
and I'm going to go to the top of the
chili and remove these grant places for
their own on the the antiquary searches
for truth and I'm going to meet the
people there and I would see what
happens but I but my belief was that it
would be that we would find these sort
of digital threshold questions of nature
and potentially the next pair attention
to the next
there are
[Music]
like the most peaceful a schism between
we can talk about how we the that's one
affection to become a good test run said
why beings as a tower
instead instead of a second reaction to
be the most important group convincing
every fantasy money now detective it's a
myriad from Dark Matter particle shapes
the name of this galaxy which would be
it doesn't have to city and as a special
after every album should see a field
interaction response Amy the part that
not every album of every materials would
effectively
[Music]
we develop so that's why this sample is
so personal
but there are alternative models by
other techniques for example axioms
axiom is a great life partner with
Dragon Nest particle very tiny can be
honourable and excellent can actually be
converted into a whole
so you have
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
takes all the data the worst case
scenario is not that we don't find any
new particles the worst case scenario is
that Jill theorists raises her hand and
says ah the regime didn't find new
particles because you didn't do the
right type of analysis you didn't keep
the right events that would suck
you never lose sight of a larger picture
which is that we are part of decades
centuries and generations long project
to understand more about the fundamental
underpinnings of the universe
you have participated in the collective
scientific inquiry of humankind
so we keep looking and every time that
we don't find this particle it just
means it is much more rarely interact
with normal matter that because is much
more rare than what we even dream of it
so we need to be even smarter and we can
make things even more quiet or nice very
active if you like to look forward so we
still have quite a ways to go and ok
give me the next experiment description
said 8000 kilogram or more cleaner the
largest we I never cared about going
there babe so in order to increase the
chance that we have to manage to detect
once we clean the name
[Music]
[Music]
so things a noble gas up there so week 2
- nominee receiver so it's not that cold
peaceful so really we find his talents
so that when he's liquid these three
times and even water remains liquid and
so being a lately we need to contain
that the school so we determined so
amazing we have the so-called crisis so
we put safeguards include animals in
liquid form into a thermal thing into a
caisson is insulated to because it's
cold and to attend that this particle
away here to set off another movie
detector what will happen is that the
staggering produces this is a tiny
amount of energy in this cohesion and
that is the energy are we looking for to
measure the weight measurement and
radiation in a medium you actually see
the radiation in different ways for
instance wheat or we look forward slash
to the light scintillation light just
because we suckers get excited happens
within which our feet like this particle
and excited nothing the sense of the
excitement in big dog will further
inform excited states and through the PA
citational disease we have simulation
both we have lectures of lives and we
use a detective series this is the main
thing that we're looking forward let us
say as a proof that there was an
interaction in the liquid diamond but of
course many other party extending the
same and that is the only great
agreement we are looking for that little
black sand
[Music]
billions of interaction across the
grades that affinity our research for
that time for that element is a theory
[Music]
it's not like you ain't going to be
buddy c49
so I have to say I'll give it the
leanest here is not complete so he has
put forward the basic idea where these
people trying to spy on different issues
that he has because and utility has to
be able to display all the phenomena
that we see including costing expanding
looking that's the visa so forgiveness
users I feel explain on yet explain
these presence of elevation to places so
he's still working on I think is the
fundamental pressure but he needs way of
thinking about it doesn't need dark
matter to in these galaxies
[Music]
assume in your self-interest and it
basically is in the war and that's a
problem or keep saying so but since we
are moving somewhere table here that
people need and the being dominant by
other parties to your body every day but
be very direct to the business possible
the same thing you will pass with
abundance that concentrated into that
the differences in the integrity
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so indeed very challenging Parliament
about the same but these events are just
from around ability to know don't
parents and after one year I mean signal
that's all
so mostly man recorded average is from
the north back and we one sentence in
Sunday
so we have them stand out that one thank
you we can say confidently that not all
that
[Music]
[Applause]
you